[Applaudissements]
les amis de l'abitibi mes amis d et de
la madeleine mes amis rencontrés sur les
dix mille kilomètres que nous avons
parcouru pendant cette campagne
mes très chers amis nous n'avons pas ce
soir le résultat que nous espérions nous
nous sommes lancés dans ce marathon
électoral avec un programme à la fois
ambitieux et concret une détermination
sans borne à faire progresser les
régions du québec à soutenir les
familles du québec à défendre
l'environnement du québec a érigé ici un
québec plus équitable plus français un
québec libre
nous l'avons fait avec rigueur les avec
bonne humeur
nous l'avons fait avec une formidable
équipe de candidats un nombre record de
candidates
un nombre record de jeunes et nous avons
innové en menant cette campagne en
tandem avec notre vice chef qui est en
route de joliette pour nous se joindre à
nous véronique hivon que je salue celui
là avec moi
[Applaudissements]
bon moment
au moment de lancer sur les chemins
notre magnifique autobus
nous savions que le terrain ne nous
était pas favorable
j'ai cherché longtemps la comparaison
qui rendrait justice aux défis que nous
avions devant nous les québécois
souhaitaient massivement tourner la page
sur les années libéral ce qui était
excellent mais avait identifié depuis un
an un instrument de changement possible
la coalition avenir québec de françois
legault dont le principal argument était
qu'il n'avait jamais gouverné
nous avons donc misé notre campagne sur
notre argument le plus fort
la crédibilité nous avons voulu
démontrer que nous étions le changement
crédible et nous avons à mon avis passé
les tests de crédibilité sérieusement
sérieux
[Applaudissements]
cependant la volonté populaire de
choisir la cac pour s'assurer de déloger
les libéraux était plus forte que tout
il s'agissait d'un cul de courants
puissants irrésistible les gens viennent
à ma comparaison qui m'a trotté dans la
tête pendant toute la campagne pour
l'emporter et nous fallait remonter les
chutes du niagara à la rame et nous
avons ramé mes amis nous avons ramé à
nous en arracher la peau des mains on
vous l'avait dit en début de campagne
les péquistes sont comme les dentistes
ils en arrachent mais c'est pour votre
bien
[Applaudissements]
nous avons fait face à une seconde
difficulté unique dans l'histoire
politique du québec alors que nous
ramenions pour remonter avec quelques
succès d'autres travaillaient dans nos
circonscriptions pour nous arracher des
rames
je voudrais saluer ce soit l'engagement
en politique de centaines de milliers de
jeunes ceux qui ont voté parti québécois
et je vous vois dans la sarre et ceux
nombreux qui ont voté québec solidaire
lorsqu on finira de calculer les votes
on se rendra compte qu'on assiste à
l'irruption d'une nouvelle génération de
souverainistes au pq et à qu est ce qui
additionné pointe à nouveau la boussole
québécoises vers l'indépendance
alors vous savez j'avais espéré j'avais
espéré il ya deux ans à l'as vence
je le voyais je le visualiser cet
engouement nouveau de la jeunesse autour
du pq et de québec solidaire et je
proposais que nos deux parties
additionnent leurs forces
notre offre était sincère ici le congrès
de q est-ce avait accepté notre main
tendue il ya fort à parier que
l'élection de ce soir offrirait un tout
autre résultat
l'intense activité militante que nous
avons dû concentrer pour nous battre
dans nos propres comptes et nous les
aurions déployer ensemble pour conquérir
d'autres circonscriptions et qui sait
changer l'issue du scrutin
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas réécrire le
passé mais il faut en tirer des leçons
pour l'avenir
pour l'heure le peuple a parlé
la cac a gagné j'ai appelé tout à
l'heure françois legault pour le
féliciter lui et son équipe pour cette
victoire décisive
j'ai dit à france soir la caq c'est
souvent plaît de se faire voler ses
idées par le parti de gouvernement
eh bien nous c'est le contraire je
t'invite françois toi et tes futurs
ministres à lire notre programme et
apprendre le maximum d'idées possible
[Applaudissements]
il est possible
ils n'ont pas dit non il n'a pas dit non
dit regarde surtout le bout sur
l'environnement et fasse des face à
l'entente honteuse conclu hier entre
justin trudeau et donald trump
monsieur le premier ministre désigné
françois legault le parti québécois sera
au rendez-vous de l'unité du québec pour
faire front à cette épreuve
[Applaudissements]
le aussi salué les pouillard les manon
massé pour leurs victoires respectives
ma plus grande tristesse ce soir c'est
de voir l'assemblée nationale privée à
partir de demain de femmes et d'hommes
de grands talents que j'ai eu le
privilège de côtoyer au sein du caucus
du parti québécois et de connaître comme
candidates et candidats pendant cette
campagne
écoutez moi bien les 125 le verdict de
l'électorat ne porte pas sur votre
talent votre dévouement ou votre amour
du québec
vous avez été emporté par une vague
et lorsque la vague se retira vous serez
toujours là debout et vaillant comme
comme des québécoises et des québécois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je veux remercier tous nos travailleurs
de l'ombre toute l'équipe avec moi dans
l'autobus psychédélique ou à la
permanence à la recherche aux relations
de presse et aux communications aux
réseaux sociaux aux tournées à
l'organisation au soutien à l'accueil
notre monde qui venait jour après jour
faire des appels comme celles et ceux
qui sillonnait le québec
mille fois merci france à mios qui fut
la force tranquille derrière tout ce que
nous avons accompli et tout ce que nous
voulions accomplir
sylvie mon amoureuse qui a introduit
dans le petite histoire politique du
québec la légende des smoothie et dont
la présence est la vraie source de mon
énergie
[Applaudissements]
je salue surtout les 80 mille membres du
parti québécois
ces dizaines de milliers de militants
dans toutes les circonscriptions qui
avait consacré temps énergie pour nos
candidats pour notre cause on voulait
davantage mais tout ce qu'on a eu c'est
grâce à vous les militants du parti
québécois
[Applaudissements]
une vague d'une autre nature a touché ma
propre circonscription de heureusement
je tiens à saluer et à remercier les
citoyennes et citoyens heureusement
qu'ils m'ont fait confiance pendant les
six dernières années mme ofran ainsi
plusieurs des plus belles saisons de ma
vie merci véronique bergeron
merci jean pierre silvain merci mireille
arvisais et tous les autres
le verdict de heureusement met également
un terme à l'emploi le plus formidable
que j'ai jamais eu
celui de chef du parti québécois je
serai à vos côtés lors des prochaines
batailles toujours je prends ma grande
part de responsabilité dans le résultat
d'aujourd'hui mais j'aime croire aussi
j'aime croire aussi j'aime croire aussi
que le parti ciment son organisation son
financement
son programme son énergie en disent bien
plus long sur notre travail commun des
deux dernières années que le nombre de
nos députés
il ya 50 ans cette année un grand parti
voyait le jour ce parti notre parti
votre parti le parti québécois a donné
énormément au québec
et franchement il veut continuer et en
donner encore plus nous avons eu cinq
fois le privilège de former le
gouvernement du québec et de la loi 101
à la sortie du nucléaire
nous avons su bien utiliser ce privilège
pour tous les gens de ce pays
nous assumons le choc ce soir mais nous
nous tenons droit et fort parce que le
québec a encore besoin du parti
québécois tant et aussi longtemps
[Applaudissements]
tant et aussi longtemps qu'il y aura des
combats à mener pour la justice l'équité
l'environnement la laïcité
le français le québec aura besoin du
parti québécois tant que le québec ne
sera pas un pays le québec aura besoin
du parti québécois
merci
jean françois lisée qui annonce donc
qu'il quitte ses fonctions de chef du
parti québécois